lo sai che tanto state scalpitando tutti
come dei puledri va bene iniziamo un
anno fa ragazzi io ho fatto un gioco
chiamato a ogni va bene ecco da quando
ho finito con giocoli tutti quanti ne
avete cagato al cazzo perché voleva che
giocassi a gironi che questo sarebbe il
seguito novembre 2003 la storia riguarda
sei persone che sono entrate in una casa
abbandonata di zona tanto per cambiare
guarda eccolo qua western vira poi
medical center e quindi in questo posto
è un po scepi cazzo vuol dire non so che
cosa ti aspettavi
non c'è nessuno qua dentro sin dagli
anni cinquanta la ma dopo ryan sarà bene
o che è successo è caduto è svenuto si è
cagato addosso un fantasma dovrebbe
averlo ucciso tempo di tornare a casa
sembra che abbia sembra molto caldo
magari c'è un lavandino qui da qualche
parte dovrebbe esserci un bicchiere o
una tanica o un secchio da tirargli in
faccia beffati a mente
vado a prenderli qualcosa bravo poco
prima da solo e mi raccomando sia mai
che qualcuno va spero che non si perde
per favore fa presto a ciò andati in due
assicurati di fare in fretta un game
seafrance i presa
che bello io sono qui viviamo basta
musica tutta dentro è necessaria
sono giocatori di un bambino sta morendo
amico la cucina della tradizione la
madonna sta morendo
va bene fate vedere questa la cucina
cosa con la chiave inglese chiave della
cucina ottenuta posso rianimarlo con una
chiave faccio prima cosa da quanto tempo
alla musica porca vacca bloccato la
porta con la chiave della cucina bene
qualcuno c'ha un bicchiere o qualcosa lì
o ecco forse questo o il frigorifero
sempre ancora funzionante ma a nessuno
viene più qui ho ottenuto bicchiere
d'acqua
c'è un bicchiere d'acqua che che dagli
anni 50 che sta lì e tu l'hai presa bene
fa niente chiede d'acqua negli anni 50
come muore solo a vederlo
a farcelo gas elettricità se n'è andata
si sennò faresti avresti dei problemi
alla vista devo sempre così vai a
prendere un bicchiere d'acqua i tuoi
amici e poi questo al tago non è da
sempre facciamo televisione roma che
batte ci guardiamo un bel film horror un
amico ovviamente sparito tutti spariti
scommette da culo che beta guro un tipo
di sushi secondo me da puro dove cazzo
sei posso andare lì sopra ci sarà ancora
qualcuno ovviamente no ma ti pareva e
fatemi indovinare se prova ad uscire la
porta è chiusa
ci sono delle catene alla parola ma dava
addirittura le catene ben 82 tier1 e
core a facetime in testa sbaglia sicuro
quanto tana degli stessi scena flash
light o mild fa in serie a broken come
la bussola flashlight aiuto a flash
annuncia le batte pure le batterie
minchia casi siamo bravi treni ci
permette takuro e chi siamo dove cazzo
stata muro è sparito c'è una chiave
dietro delle scale se però devi stare
cambio posso spingere le scatole bene mi
fa piacere a ok
beh io sono sempre stato un fenomeno in
questi giochi
intelligenza vi preoccupate che risolve
subito so se così i ragazzi
probabilmente no però devo provarci in
qualche modo e la maniera giusta il
giusto per di più oddio aspetto risotto
fenomeno un fenomeno ma torna regala
professor lei non mi fa una pippa a due
mani e un registro di tutti i visitatori
che l'ospedale ha mai avuto le date
risalgono al 1800 è la madonna quanto
abbandonato sto posto a sbloccare una
porta con la porta del bagno si però io
vorrei che i nostri
ciao takeshi collega sei fatto entrare
che una vita chiave non lo sapremo mai
takeshi stai bene due sono gli altri
shivering non so cosa voglia dire ma chi
trema tre matite takeshi tremende
takeshi di chiamate utile questo takeshi
che cazzo guai per uno mobile parte ii
ha ottenuto flash led
ho messo la parole la batteria della
flashlight va bene ma non me la fa usare
ma vabbé non fa niente ci sono dei
pantaloni questo sì che un bel giorno
qualcuno si stava divertendo è un paio
di jeans
sembra proprio che qualcuno tentasse di
tenere lontano delle persone da questa
parte
eccolo casa hanno fatto la barricata
server e non avevo visto non l'avevo per
l'intervista ma spero che non sia
qualcuno del mio team
andiamo di sopra l'ho visto è non fare
il pezzo di merda c'era c'era un mostro
che io conosco molto bene che ha dato
qua sinistra non prendetemi per il culo
a un computer erano gallo su facebook
non funziona non funziona cosa metti a
fare computer ci metti il computer è in
bella vista che illumina la stanza non
funziona proprio tramite bricolo pesante
avrei piacere di capire che questi ci
enorme che è passato di qui anche se lo
so già è tornato ma se stavi a casa
forse era meglio sai mi spiega perchè
continuano a togliere
la corrente alle cose per favore
che fastidio questo giorno una persona
che co.na che castra collins locali
colpa donovan e vabbè magari si sono
attivati i costi per mariti e guido ma
[ __ ] [ __ ] quindi si riaccende la
luce spuntare il mio bell'uomo ragazzi
sono riusciti a farlo molto più
raccapricciante nel primo a ogni che
vuol dire tanto è perché lo avrebbe
introdotto prima adesso ancora più
brutto è una vacca aiuto aiuto e anche
brutto gioco si faccia bruttissimo stato
tagliato un occhio cos'è che sento il
rumore del mare che problemi partendo il
rumore delle onde un po strano dov'è
andato a finire lo zero ma perché seppur
rumore del mare nel normale sto gioco 1
f cardone ho tenuto una carta sconto
fedeltà sconto fedeltà mostri negli
ospedali dice fra ci sono ma non ho solo
il dato di sonno
permesso non è che questa tessera apre
per caso l'apporto scorretto eccola lì
perfetto slicing di slot of the door
fantastici permesso sono riuscito a
scoprire st parte del gioco quindi onore
a me la porta è chiusa
ci mancava quando permesso o non fatemi
apparire mostri alla cazzo dica perché
io parlo e non sto zitto e vai avanti si
va avanti piano piano c'è un microonde
forti te lo porto a casa
a noi la batte una cassaforte ma per
quanto impossibile ad azzeccare 89 24 24
uno si apre l'altro una la mamma degli
haters l'altra la mamma di tutti gli
altri perché mensa aperta st porta se
prima era chiusa ha permesso era chiusa
un secondo fa come non mi fate apparire
mostri che non so come scappare per
cortesia è chiave piccolo ottenuta bene
perché la porta con la chiave piccolo va
bene chi è capo comitato sul banco usa
gli armati per scappare dal mostro
vecchi coach arancione arrivato ziona
ben si
poi cascata lampada qualcuno che mi fa
andare per caso di sopra non c'è chiave
pulita perché aveva tre erano sporche
scusami saranno interrate nel deretano
scommetti che esce qualcuno dalle scale
dietro nostra l'avrei detto ho sbloccato
la porta con la chiave pulita la battuta
donne col maestro quante volte l'ho già
detto nei video non abbastanza ecco
mezza chiave ottenuto ha visto gioco
trovi sono chiari in giro e non chiavi
mai scherzi che ha sporcato di sangue
una serie ora la madonna sono i giorni
della settimana sunday minchia pur in
inglese ma che qui sand mandela mi
daresti web based fridays at the happy
days ha funzionato c'è una piccola
scritta al fondo 27 trattenuto attivo e
la password di colori prima
ne mancano altre due quindi figure vabbè
bello la madonna che la giochiamo in
giro questa è l'altra parte della chiave
scommetti botto anarchy perfetto da
parte di sotto della chiave adesso
dovete fare andando a quali uniche tutti
la porta che rimane questa o storici web
c'è un mostro più grossi me lo sento di
virtus e meravigliosa mica sei
meravigliosa lascito vetta culo è
sparito 10 non uscirò mai l'acqua come
un mostro che scappa va bene allora di
una ciotola 6 proprio tipo che dà
risposte del genere conti solo su se
stesso è un adozione o stai qua o vieni
con me è visto posso fidarmi di te
rimani lì vicino
sì andiamo dai andiamo stammi vicino i
colli problemi mentali sofri e appena
detto tu stanno vicine esci massei
[ __ ] ma di quale malattia 24
comunque 27 24 ne manca ancora uno ma
stai qua ma sei scema
se poi chi uccide passandosi chiuso
nell'armadio racchiuso nella mani o
brutta son cubano ha potuto legati
ma [ __ ] ma perché si sono tese
questo io voi questo sono io che questo
se stesso non ho parole come sculato dei
alla fine a [ __ ] a ok e quindi
ragazzi questo era il primo episodio di
mira honey che spero vi sia piaciuto
visto che mai estate tar passando le
balle da tipo un anno per farlo consente
al momento è un mi piace anche ora con
il dott descrizione il prossimo episodio
uscirà tra pochissimi giorni quindi dei
pronti soccorsi si scateni ci vediamo un
possibilità da ragazzi
mai vecchia